having a deal do you think this is for
top gear and for Clarkson I think it's a
massive deal I mean the BBC is as they
say in deep crisis now because this
isn't just you know a presenter of a
little program that's got into a bit of
trouble the top gear over the years has
generated hundreds of millions of pounds
for the BBC
Jeremy Clarkson is the figurehead of
that programme he is top gear it looks
as if this time you may have gone too
far if top gear loses jeremy clarkson it
will plunge it into a world of trouble
he has been on a final warning for a
while now the Radio Times we don't know
whether this is true but the Radio Times
is a good and reliable source he's
saying he punched someone I mean yeah
given the position he was in a few
possibly do that well you have to wonder
he must have gone jolly cross or wanted
to be fired I mean there receive er
wanting there developing a car based
panel show I understand so so I said I
got news heresy well you know and there
are other potential homes mr. Clarkson
than on the BBC and we saw with Jonathan
Ross that when he behaved very badly and
was effectively fired by the BBC he
ended up on the other side quite quickly
well yes how do you think he would feel
about potentially losing his job how
important do you think this has been to
him I think as Neil suggests there'll be
a home for him at some other channel
probably ITV would snap him up but I
think he'll be devastated by this I mean
apart from the fact that Top Gear has
become his spiritual home it's made him
an absolute fortune he's making millions
a year out of it so there's an income
issue here but of course both him and
the BBC due to the various fracas that
he's been involved in over the years
have steered themself into a position
where they've got nowhere else to go you
know last time they said this is his
final warning that was with the N word
and then and then he wrote in this
column in the Sun I have been given
categorically my last warning
so I don't see what can come of this
and except his dismissal I mean I have
to be I'm not a regular viewer of Top
Gear but when I watch it I do admire him
as a professional I mean he is
absolutely brilliant to these eight
billion showed if you like that sort of
he's a great presenter where I might
diverge from from Kevin a bit is that I
think the show will continue and a lot
of the time TV executives think we must
keep the talent and the BBC were very
keen on keeping Jonathan Ross during the
the Ross brand I mean the out shows got
Alan teed but they don't have the purse
IT or the board well not yet I mean when
Adrian and Christine interview Bleakley
and Adrian Charles and Christine
Bleakley left the one show that was
supposed to be a big crisis for the One
Show and the One Show just continued
Danny's is as popular as it ever was
I mean there's right I mean there's no I
wasn't suggesting that they'll get rid
of top gear top gear will continue
because of the amount of money it
generates and it is arguably this is at
the 20 second series is arguably the
BBC's most successful brand and program
of all time they're not going to ditch
it was one guy list but it but it will
be incalculable damaged by the loss of
Jeremy Clarkson he epitomizes everything
that programs about I don't Kevin I
think you've met him haven't you yeah
watch I was there the last time we threw
a punch 2004 the press Awards well
reserves were any dektor while he tried
to deck by then editor Piers Morgan
pitch Morgan I should say as tweeted a
picture saying I'm right behind you it's
a picture of Clarkson going like that
and then behind him is the young Piers
Morgan go get generously put himself on
for the job by the way already but but
knowing him a little bit would you say
that he's very much as you see him on
screen I mean or is he playing a persona
to a certain extent but no I think with
Jeremy I think that I mean like don't
profess to be his best friend but I
think what you see is what you get and
that's his charm and that's also his big
problem
he doesn't really act up for you know he
doesn't play the game in real life and
don't forget culturally Top Gear has
sort of set itself against modern PC
values so in a way if you keep teeth
yeah well the kind of they were already
saying he'll either be the kept the
candidate forum Kensington or I'll join
you kit but they deliberately walk on
egg eggshells and I'm afraid you know
this has got them into too much trouble
and of course we don't know the details
at all there's an investigation going on
he's just been suspended at this stage
but if he if he were to walk what do you
think Neil what happened to him next
well I think though it depends what he's
done because obviously there's a
difference between doing something
offensive and committing a crime if he's
really hurt somebody by punching them
then of course he might have to go away
and serve the dependents if it's more as
the BBC said in a statement Africa where
there was a bit of a scuffle between two
people on a TV set then I think he
probably probably will be a bidding war
for him between ITV and sky don't forget
that ITV as of the next football season
have lost their Champions League rights
an ITV are expressly trying to get shows
at the moment that will appeal more to
male viewers well who appeals more to
male viewers than Jeremy clubs I think
that the BBC's statement which said no
one else was involved was as good as
saying this is it he's gone too far this
is a beauty by much been involved it's
not a real cell no no nobody else has
been suspended okay
alright thank you very much your deep
thank you